this week's honest trailer is brought to
you by dnd beyond dnd is for everyone
dnd beyond makes it easy to play
register for free at dndbeyond.com to
start your adventure
[Music]
after 15 years and four blockbuster
films it's finally time to say goodbye
to daniel craig as james bond just not a
really quick goodbye you know one of
those goodbyes when you're at a bar with
friends you haven't seen in a while so
it takes forever to leave and you keep
bumping the more people you know on your
way out by the time you get outside you
realize that you forgot your credit card
you have to head back in to close out
your tab and then wait 40 minutes for
your uber to show up it's that kind of
goodbye we have all the time in the
world
no time to die
get ready for a dour self-serious final
chapter for a dour self-serious james
bond who transformed a franchise where
this kind of thing used to happen
to one where this kind of thing tends to
happen for what felt like five minutes
of my life i wanted everything with you
and i do not regret a single moment of
my life that led me to you
in this epic that signals the end of the
craig era and the beginning of what will
in all likelihood be i don't know chris
pratt apparently used to be everyone now
come on i'm bond james bond man who
experience a feature-length epilogue to
the story they've been telling since
casino royale in a sleek linear
narrative about james bond's fight
against quantum herb spectre and its
vicious leader rao silva
no aide bluefield who's dead set on
getting revenge on m no bun actually
it's bond no you know what he's out for
revenge on madeleine swann's dad who is
javier bardem i think no that can't be
right proving once and for all that
james bond could work as a linear
franchise if there weren't three years
between each film what is it with your
dad in secret rooms you think i remember
her dad was introduced during the bush
administration
meet bond james bond a man who needs to
bond james bond with some friends or
family because i'm seriously worried
about him this time watch as he's pushed
to the absolute edge of clinical
depression
writing the fine line between alcoholic
and british
[Music]
well i have another drink for three or
four hour
hours wow doesn't sound like cute and
losing interest in seducing women with
foreign accents and a taste for danger
you're excellent you too
ciao okay i've headed off they're
allowed to get old but once bond loses
their mojo you got to send them to the
farm upstate don't worry little matilda
it's gonna love it up there plenty of
mountain roads to drive through
recklessly and all the martinis are
shaking never stirred
[Music]
after bond spent a decade fighting
spectre a new mastermind will take them
all out in a single hot havana night now
bun will face off against this new evil
threat 7. rami malik's creepiest role
since that airline commercial i'm a fan
of chamomile tea
i'm a fan of handwritten letters
i'm a fan of
classic movies
watch as he steals a biological weapon
more powerful than several of bond's
stds once ericles is in your system it's
there forever and once he's done using
it in a targeted mission of personal
revenge he'll go full genocidal maniac
because well i don't know just look at
him he's got scars if something's wrong
with the face they hate the human race
that's just bond logic
while bob is off moping around his
jamaican shag pad it's up to surly's
angels to save the day like bon's old
flame dr madeleine swann the type of
bond girl who's not just there to get
kidnapped and rescued i mean she does do
that she does get kidnapped and need to
be rescued but only after first giving
bond a child how the progressive then
there's nomi the new double07 who breaks
down every barrier including the fourth
wall because no one in universe should
care that much about an employee id
number right i'm not just any old double
o i'm double o seven w seven that must
bother you he's been reinstated as a
double o double o what double o what
permission for commander bond to be
redesignated as double seven it's just a
number it is just a number unless all
the characters watch bond movies too and
ana de armas as paloma who spends 10
minutes making the audience say who is
that
and 150 minutes making the audience say
where did paloma go can we check in on
her again i'm bored
so strap in for the film that boldly
transforms the ultimate male escapist
fantasy into an emotionally shattered
divorced dad who just wants to know what
to feed a french kid for breakfast i
don't know crepes voodrevo crepes that
ties up this bond era by killing the
character on screen for the very first
time
but do they really it's pretty clear
this man is immune to explosions at this
point
the guy explodes himself a little bit
each morning build up an immunity he'll
be back
see
starring
the five five-timers club hot shots
parts a dew that guy is poison
never tries to prune face and a smile
hashtag girl bond the pringles they are
how you say delicious a literal bond
girl q v q dude people are looking for
you man agent pam
see saw motor functions
hannibal specter
he who should not be named mallory
law and order suv
[Music]
beginner's pluck and
why would you want to look at your eye
is there something wrong with that weird
eye
james and the giant bridge
seven's old plan kind of ends up like
the plot of the rock taking place on an
island using bio weapons with the intent
to kill millions having the hero still
on it when the bombs arrive if only
craig had some help from a former bond
losers always whine about their best
winners go home and the prom queen
this week's honest trailer is brought to
you by dnd beyond battle for beyond
subscribe to ddb's youtube to join the
battle
fuzzy wuzzy was a bear fuzzy wuzzy had
no hair so fuzzy wuzzy wasn't very fuzzy
was he